-Welcome back to the show, everybody.
You know, not a lot of things are certain in this crazy world.
We scurry through life lickety-split
from one fleeting experience to another.
Nothing seems sacred anymore. Nothing seems permanent.
And that's why this week at "The Tonight Show,"
we're saluting the one thing we know is still permanent --
THE permanent.
A.k.a. the permanent wave. A.k.a. the perm.
That's right. It's the return of "Tonight Show Perm Week."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ On the Fallon show ♪
♪ Oh, my God ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is "Tonight Show Perm Week,"
the very special week... [ Laughter ]
...where every day we pick someone
from our audience and stylishly perm their hair.
Tonight's lucky perm recipient is Tyler Toledo.
Oh, wow.
Tyler is 22 years old. He's from Whitestone, New York.
And he's very excited about his new hairdo.
It's been a big day for Tyler. Take a look.
-Hi. I'm Tyler Toledo. And today I'm getting a perm.
I have never thought about getting a perm before.
I've always just kind of been the type to just like,
"Ah, let it grow, see what happens."
I'm a little nervous to get a perm,
but I'm very open to change in my life right now.
-I'm Tyler's dad. -And we're Tyler's friends,
and we can't wait to see what he looks like with a perm.
-I wouldn't change Tyler's hair,
but I support him on his journey.
The only other person that I know that has a perm
is my mother, and I look at the pictures, and I wonder why.
-My grandmother had a perm in the '70s,
and you look at all those old pictures
and she absolutely killed it. -And now Tyler's getting a perm,
and I'm also wondering why.
-I'm hoping Tyler doesn't look like Hagrid from "Harry Potter."
He's got the beard, too, so it's likely.
-I don't think the world is ready
for what they're about to see -- a whole different Tyler.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Yeah. A whole different Tyler.
Now, Tyler has been sequestered since he got permed,
so he hasn't seen himself yet.
And his dad and his friends haven't seen him, either.
This entire process has been cloaked in secrecy.
We've got his dad and his friends right here.
Hello, guys. How you guys doing?
Nice to see you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dad, you couldn't perm your hair if you tried.
-No, no, no. Not at all, Jimmy.
-You've got short, short, short hair.
And you had a great Hagrid line. That was pretty funny.
-Thank you. -Yeah, you're welcome.
Alright, now, do not remove the blindfolds
until I tell you, okay?
Are you excited? -Very excited.
-Yes. Yeah. -Alright. Very good.
Audience, are you ready? Are you ready...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...for the brand-new freshly permed Tyler?
Here is Tyler before.
And here he is now. Tyler, come on out!
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
-Can you do a 360? -That's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stand right on the star. -I'm so excited.
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
Wow! Tyler, you look great.
Do you feel great?
-I feel incredible. -Wow.
Uh, guys, are you ready to see Tyler?
-Yes. -Yeah.
-Hold hands. Hold hands and follow me.
-Alright. [ Laughter ]
-We're getting closer and closer.
Do not take off your blindfolds yet.
Alright. Who are you most excited to see your new look?
Dad?
-He's -- He's seen every single one of my hairdos.
This is gonna be a unique one.
-This will be a --
-One he's never seen before.
-Proud papa/son moment.
Alright. Whenever you guys are ready, take off your blindfolds.
-Ohh!
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
-I like it. I like it.
-I like it.
-You're like twins almost.
-No, we don't look like twins.
Much better-looking.
Now for the most important reveal of all.
Tyler, are you ready to see yourself?
-I'm about as ready as I can be. -You ready for this?
-Ready. -Three, two, one.
Have a look.
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause ]
-I like it. -I like it, too.
-It's a good look.
It's a good -- You got a good face.
It's a good look.
Our thanks to the Randy Darden Hair Salon
for this wonderful perm.
We're giving out perms every night this week.
Happy Perm Week, everybody.
We'll be right back with Liam Neeson.
Come on back.
♪ It's Perm Week on the Fallon show ♪